dear prime ministers
deputy prime ministers
dear colleagues ladies and gentlemen
it is a pleasure to join you today
even if only virtually
i have a very simple message for you
today
central asia matters to europe and
europe matches to central asia
in the 30 years since your independence
central asian economies grew almost
non-stop
until the pandemic hit all of us
our cooperation can help restart our
economic engine
and at the same time it can make central
asian economies stronger fairer and more
sustainable in the long run
and this is exactly what we are pushing
for in europe too
we are using the massive investment in
our recovery plan to reshape our economy
we are speeding up the transition to
clean energy
we are connecting more people and
companies with digital infrastructure
and we are promoting the decisive
reforms
that europeans have been demanding for
years
green recovery digitalization
and a stronger business climate
these are also the three points on
today's agenda
europe has unparalleled expertise in all
of these fields
and we are offering greater cooperation
to all countries in central asia
in our mutual interest
executive vice president valdis
dombrovskis
will outline in his address
a few proposals to reach this goal
and he will also tell you more about our
new connectivity strategy
called global gateway europe
but allow me to run quickly through the
three topics on our
agenda first on the green recovery
central asia is already suffering from
the consequences of climate change
this summer's droughts has destroyed
harvests killed animals
and emptied reservoirs
but central asia also has an immense
untapped potential for renewable energy
with the right investment
your region can become less dependent on
coal and other fossil fuels
creating quality jobs
and cleaning the air that you breathe
so let us work together
so that green investment can drive the
economic recovery
second
digitalization
the answer to this
is not just to build new infrastructure
but also to improve rules and
regulations for the digital market
europe has a lot to offer in this
respect
because this is what we are doing at
home too
the european path to digitalization
puts people
companies and their rights at the center
and this is what we are putting on the
table
and third on the business environment
europe is already the biggest foreign
investor and the biggest trade partner
in many of your countries
europe is the source
or the destination of one third of your
international trade flows
yet i am convinced
that the potential
exists to make our partnership even
stronger
and for this companies want to know that
they can compete on a level playing
field
that they can trust your judicial
systems and the rule of law
this is also the foundation of a
sustainable growth model
one that creates jobs and prosperity in
central asia for your people and for
future generations too
all of these principles will be at the
heart of global gateway europe our new
connectivity strategy
global gateway europe will be all about
investing in our mutual interests
we want to create links
not dependencies
and central asia is
the global gateway by definition
you stand at the center of eurasia
your prosperity matters to europe
and i'm convinced that our partnership
can truly matter to your people too
so thank you and let me wish you an
excellent eu central asia economic forum